how many people can you fit in one of
these we can fit 38 people into each
cabin and here we can do about 2,200
people an hour before always having
through mostly utilized how much does it
cost for Ryan I wanted the ticket price
is posted at $32 for a ride and that
would be the price if you came at the
peak periods like on an evening on a
weekend but at other times of the day
it's often discounted off that price so
i hear that i'm going to be able to
actually see all of Vegas on this you
are going to be able to see all things
so we have less than a minute for
everyone to get off the wheel as it
arrives in the station and get on so
jump on it moves at one foot a second so
that's the statue see how I think there
isn't that there is a data for you had
fallen off we can retrieve you so this
could be where you had your bachelorette
party you could have your wedding here
we've had some already have a corporate
event you could have a Bloomberg event
you could have mr. Bloomberg here
telling you about whatever you'd like to
tell you you could program your own
party music your own videos you could
have a training event family reunion
recent emotions will work on the screen
were sloppy
how to come up with the idea of a ferris
wheel well we were trying to solve a
specific problem if you look down our
link here you see then we're asking our
guests to come about 1,200 feet off the
strip east and to get people to walk
1,200 feet to something you've got to
have an attraction in that hit several
different dimensions it has to move a
lot of people it has to be open every
day and it has to be attractive all
hours of the day so it can't be just a
nightclub or a shopping destination it
has to be something that gets a lot of
people interested which is twenty-four
seven and it can generate 2200
passengers an hour so we started looking
around at the world of this type of
attraction we looked at the women i
looked at the roller coaster down here
at the stratosphere and the numbers were
impressive and we came to the view that
if we can do this properly and make a
modern version of that experience we
could generate the kind of visitation we
wanted for this area why do you need to
get people back into the middle well we
need to because if you begin to look
around as we're leaving the station
everything you see around here we own
and operate so harris is our hotel this
is what's now called the quad we were
behind the Flamingo Caesar's Palace is
across the street on the other side
valleys and Paris and so on so it's the
I am this is all us we have 360
contiguous acres of land around here
including is undeveloped land appliance
so what we want to do is get the
customers of our competitors to have an
interesting coming into what is really
the 50-yard line of Vegas the Flamingo
Las Vegas Boulevard intersection and
have things of interest for them to do
here the other what is there to do here
well in addition to the existing casinos
and all the amenities they offer what's
in the link is a series of affordable
retail dining and entertainment options
so things like Brooklyn Bowl
you're a great concert in ball drink and
party unique retail experiences of don't
exist anywhere else in Vegas yard house
is here for example we have a sprinkles
cupcake destination losers and very
expensive and really good we do those in
New York so there's all sorts of things
that are only here as retail has
developed in vegas there's for example a
number of Louboutins tours of us or
they're all level but there's lots of
everything that's in the link is more
affordable it's more accessible it's an
outdoor and indoor experience it's open
24 7 it's fun so why affordable and when
you think Vegas you think extravagant
you think luxury you don't necessarily
think affordable why is that important
to you well if you look at the 27
million people that walk up and down the
strip every year not all of them are
going to buy a 22 hundred dollars we
vuitton bag in fact I'm understating the
case rather substantial the vast
majority of them aren't gonna buy a 2200
ollie looped on deck but they want to
have fun they want to have a unique
experience they can't get at home and
they do have money to spend and
increasingly since 2008 that's the kind
of experience that needs to be offered
here so that's what the link is intended
to appeal so you get them all here you
get them near your casinos ideally
hopefully they go in they play it later
they drink or they eat or they shop or
they go to the spa they spend money
machine easy profits
we've got this whole new area of retail
development how tough is it to get
people to your spots well it's really
tough I mean you're here this evening if
I were to run through the list of things
you can do to entertain yourself this
evening it's a remarkable list of things
and it's really what keeps Vegas vibrant
is that all of us through this
competition are adding new things to the
offer list all the time on the one hand
that's been deviling if you're trying to
compete on the other end it's what keeps
the place market so whether it's
headliner entertainment production show
entertainment retail experiences dining
experiences the recent Boone in
nightclub experiences seven or eight of
the top 10 grossing nightclubs in the
United States or in Las Vegas so at
every level the competition is intense
and that's why we have to keep trying to
come up with distinctive offering sir
you mentioned took three years to build
this and it was 500 million dollars yeah
this and the linked together all the
things you're looking at on them it's a
lot of money at a time when there's a
lot of uncertainty about the economy and
you know Caesars is dealing with its
debt issues how did you convince people
that this was the right thing to do you
know this has been probably the simplest
thing to convince people of anything
I've dealt with it since the financial
crisis people really got the idea that
if you put a new kind of attraction in
the middle of the strip with the kind of
foot traffic we have coming north and
south on the strip with this kind of
attraction at its core it was very
likely to do well and the economics are
not too daunting it's not a
multi-billion dollar project and so this
one was really quite easy and many of
our better known shareholders and
including like
like John Paulson we're really
fascinated with this idea and thought
something like this could be candid from
are holding